[Musica]
sceglierai morire pillola blu o pillola
rossa scelta che facciamo apre una
strada ma purtroppo ne chiude un'altra a
far morire un altra scelta
ed è per questo che in punto di morte
quando ripercorreremo la nostra vita
alla fine saremo la somma di tutte le
scelte che abbiamo preso scegliere dalle
cose più piccole e quotidiane alle cose
più importanti
diventa quindi determinante per il
nostro io e quindi anche una cosa molto
difficile ed è per questo che per
sfuggire a queste scelte
adottiamo tra strategie di difesa la
prima è correre sempre avevano vita così
frenetica anche un tipo di ma le domande
non tiziano i maiali fra che stai
facendo è coerente con il tuo io se ha
senso della drizza e le stesse scelte
fatte e cambia direzione nella vita la
seconda strada per non prendere scelte
non fai niente rimanere immobili nella
propria comfort zone non è che siamo in
discussione non perdere mai queste
scelte è la terza che forse quella un
pochino più diffusa i tempi di oggi è
voler fare un po tutto no che ne attesti
tutti i fronti tutte le strade e non non
c'è mai una fino in fondo
ecco ora immaginatevi di essere alla
guida della più grande community di
viaggiatori d'italia 432mila ai
viaggiatori una community che è
cresciuta molto velocemente nel tempo in
maniera esponenziale
così velocemente che alla fine abbiamo
scelto di investire assumano le persone
e aprire una sede anche in spagna eccolo
immaginatevi all'interno di questo
contesto di crescita così importante
cosa succede arriva il covip e
ovviamente si blocca tutto viaggia
diventa impossibile e anche rimandare
delle scelte diventa impossibile a
questo punto di vista ma per forza per
scelte consapevoli e apriamo la crisis
room che cadiamo più di mille persone in
giro per il mondo dove rimpatriare mille
persone che devono tornare in italia
prima che gli aeroporti e confini
chiudessero ecco quindi che diventa
fondamentale prendere delle scelte è
passata questa crisi turistica
la domanda è siamo posti è mai stata una
crisi economica crisi aziendale ci siamo
guardati attorno
abbiamo capito che danno pena decisione
pillola rossa ci inventiamo qualcosa
pillola blu aspettiamo il 2021 che passi
tutto e va un pochino attorno abbiamo
visto che l'ecosistema la risposta
sta dando è a bloccare tutto tutti
durante lo prevedo del mondo hanno
licenziato quasi un quarto della loro
forza lavoro
la tua airbnb tripadvisor i principali
principali compagnie aeree stavano
fallendo indicato al fallimento il
comparto turistico del mondo ha perso
quasi 500 miliardi di dollari per colpa
del covip e quindi era era ovvio che la
direzione sta andando verso tira remi in
barca e aspettare di 1021 ci siamo fatti
un altra domanda solo noi sono il
turismo sta vivendo questa situazione è
la risposta è stata no
ci siamo guardati attorno l'intera
italia ha vissuto questa pandemia
abbiamo perso il 10 per cento del pil
600 mila persone hanno perso il lavoro
otto milioni di persone hanno dovuto
chiedere la cassa integrazione 4 milioni
di partite iva e hanno chiesto allo
stato un aiuto in in totale in italia
che i 12 milioni di persone hanno dovuto
subire la pandemia a livello economico
sono dovuti chiedere pillola rossa o
pillola blu
scelgo di aspettare 2021 o prendo e mi
invento qualcosa noi abbiamo scelto di
inventarci qualcosa
abbiamo scelto diventarci più di
qualcosa 43 diverse iniziative per cerca
di tenere alto il morale del team per
tenere ingaggiata alla community
per noi ormai la macchina ovviamente
qualcosa dato anche storto è normale
quando le tante strade e sei un momento
di crisi ma ecco questo servizio ha
viaggiato alla community
ai nostri viaggiatori abituati a
prendere mille voli all'anno di codice
dei rapporti diventano i codici delle
stanze i nostri viaggiatori abituati a
girare il mondo girano la casa il
viaggio va dal letto al divano ecco un
modo per tenere la community ingaggiata
e e faremo anche un pochino di rave con
il merchandising e poi arriva il nostro
dichiarazioni di crisi
prendiamo delle affissioni e
condividiamo con tutti il nostro
problema non sappiamo tutti doveva andar
via organizzano viaggi e non possiamo
più andare da nessuna parte e creiamo
questi cartelloni invitiamo alla
community
a farle delle foto cercare questi
cartelloni peccato che però questi
cartelloni in realtà non esistevano
shop ci siamo inventati però ecco
inventarsi questi cartelloni diventassi
questa campagna pubblicitaria avuto
talmente tanto dibattito sui social che
alla fine qualcuno c'è anche se tutti
gli arresti e ci ha fatto i complimenti
ecco tutto questo cosa è servito è
servito a ricevere una telefonata da chi
gestisce questi cartelloni e le abbiano
avuti per davvero dei cartelloni
cartelloni veri prova con i viaggi
immaginari perché purtroppo possiamo
essere impossibile viaggiare quindi ecco
il viaggio su marte
ecco il viaggio atlantide il viaggio all
whites il viaggio jurassic park
ecco tutte le iniziative che hanno
tenuto alto il morale non ho scelto
quella strada continuare ad esistere
inventarci qualcosa
mi sono permesso di superare quattro
mesi senza lavoro senza perdere
l'entusiasmo è essere pronti
ap e stato possibile a ripartire ari
particolarmente in italia perché
viaggiare per il mondo era era ancora
impossibile però è che è stata una
ripartenza che ci ha dato la possibilità
di guardare avanti con ottimismo e anche
a farci la domanda a chiederci cosa ci
ha insegnato la storia
se noi guardiamo nel passato ai più
grandi crisi la peste dopo la peste
stato rinascimento
dopo la seconda guerra mondiale c'è
stato il miracolo economico italiano
allora mi piace pensare che esattamente
come il piano marshall ha dato il la al
miracolo economico italiano
mi immagino questore covoni fa un po sta
di nuovo darci quella carica per
ripartire più forti di prima
vogliamo farlo perché perché ha rivisto
cigno nero il cigno nero e quelle quell
evento casuale che che potrebbe
distruggerti no ma non sono soprattutto
queste cigno nero e vogliamo dimostrare
di essere resilienti essere anti fragili
quando hai più avanti fragile se anti
fragile quando davanti a un cigno nero
non esce più debole come dovrebbe essere
ormai dalla catastrofe cp devole no essi
più forte e si preesistente dimostri di
essere anti fragile eccolo a oggi noi
segniamo le forze lavoriamo tutti
insieme come squadra possiamo davvero
guardare oltre a questo covip e
dimostrare ai santi fragili e di andare
oltre la pandemia
ho individuato tra ricette la prima è
accelerare le scelte consapevoli
la pandemia ci ha rubato un anno di vita
e siamo stati chiusi in casa e abbiamo
questo abbiamo pensato ognuno di noi nel
nostro cuore sicuramente avrà sacca
delle scelte da prendere che non ha mai
avuto il coraggio di farli continua a
rimandare il per esempio dopo 12 anni
armi no quindi acceleriamo queste scelte
il covip ci chiede questa acceleriamo
per andare oltre e poi combattiamo la
solitudine e le polarizzazioni siamo un
anno che siamo distanti dai nostri
affetti che siamo soli e che i soci
hanno polarizzato i soci sono diventati
veramente un contenitore di odio e che
dobbiamo tutti quanti insieme lavorare
per tornare a vivere socialità a vivere
in comunità ad abbracciarci ea litigare
tutte le tensioni sia fisiche che this
di cyberbullismo e il terzo è un patto
sociale patto sociale perché l'abbiamo
visto ci sono 12 milioni di italiani che
hanno avuto un impatto devastante
livello economico dal co lead e allora
in una delle ricette andiamo aiutiamoli
facciamo andiamo al bar andiamo al
ristorante andiamo al cinema teatri
chiamaci in palestra viaggiamo chi non
ha avuto un impatto economico dal co
lead fatto questo patto sociale e alle
madri notare che invece è un anno che ha
avuto un impatto significativo economico
e poi l'ultimo il patto generazionale
le nuove generazioni sono quelle meno
colpite livello sanitario ma sono quelle
che stanno pagando il conto più grande
passiamo per siamo la disoccupazione
giovanile e 30 per cento di
disoccupazione giovanile in italia gli
universitari 11 per cento in meno di
iscritti all'università
il ragazzo e superiori a dire a distanza
il 38 per cento dei ragazzi non ha
potuto fare i dati delle istanze maniera
continuativa
pensiamo ai bambini delle elementari
della materna abbiamo costretti per più
di un anno a vivere con la mascherina li
hanno privati del sorriso degli amici
degli abbracci e reinsediato east high
distante dagli altri quando invece devo
insegnare ad abbracciarci che il mondo è
uno solo andare contro alla diversità
contro alle solitudine razzismo e poi i
nati i bambini mai nati quest'anno
nasceranno si stima 20.000 bambini in
meno
ecco per tutto questo e per il fatto che
nuove generazioni dovranno pagare il
debito pubblico che avevano creato in
questo anno 150 miliardi
dobbiamo fare questo patto generazionale
e rimettere le nuove generazioni al
centro e sono certo che se faremo tutto
questo e tutti insieme lavoreremo per
accelerare scelte consapevoli combatte
la solitudine e le polarizzazioni e
saremo promotori di un patto sociale
generazionale
allora davvero come italia potremo
rivivere il nostro rinascimento
possiamo dimostrare a noi stessi al
mondo
che non solo siano stati abbiamo fatto
il cigno nero ma siamo stati anche anti
fragili e allora tutti quanti noi
un in bocca al lupo per il futuro